é esse o meu desejo é é a quem se é
claro né
com o número é assustador mensagens
escritas que os anunciantes enviam todos
os dias
serão 70 sms por dia 25 e 26 mil por ano
não contando com as casas de conversação
online nem com os 30 minutos diários que
falam alto fome ocorre por oito dias por
ano mais ou menos
nem com o facto de um quarto deus passar
seis horas 6 horas por dia ligados à
internet center por cento consideraram
aí é essa emoção com um de grande
independência surf causa das mensagens é
a rainha da festa um pouco né
continuidade do pressuposto biológico de
que função que criou o órgão que o lugar
da nossa espécie poderá ser no futuro é
provavelmente muito diferente da nossa
um pouco contra com circo por lugar do
panda aliás o que mostra o mundo mais ou
menos indo brigado com recurso a norma
alto que seguramente cedo com
singularidades humanas saem essas
imperfeições da natureza é evolução
jamais teria existido e sem elas os
próximos passos
ficaram um dos nossos antepassados nunca
teriam sido necessários
é claro que uma leitura mais
comprometida com o povo judaico cristãos
em que crescemos lugar do centro será um
instrumento protesto para nos
questionarmos acerca da criação o deus
quando criou o homem não terá ponderado
devidamente sobre o lugar dos alunos
o ter se distraído organizados com o
universo em uma fração dos
verdadeiramente flagrante não estímulo o
quanto smart phones acabariam por trazer
uma mudança radical na vida deles é
ponto determinado momento e se
questionar ct próprio criação ou ainda é
uma perspectiva mais tentador eu
reconheço simplesmente deus tomando
temendo alguma megalomania em que as
pessoas que são simultaneamente amadas e
poupada sofrimentos com tanto de
exorbitante com o desmedidos pudessem
que ir é colocou sobre os ombros dos
alunos sentes é tarefa de proteger os
pais de qualquer uma impotência conheça
o risco esteja sempre que dispõe novos
problemas é claro e os desafio para não
desistirem de consenso
às vezes eu tenho a impressão que o fim
do mundo como se depois de nós
o próximo passo é acabasse por ser
sempre pior como se o mundo e nós com
ele evoluiu espero que haja mais ou
menos assim e eu gostava que se
unicamente ao fato de estarmos juntos um
planeta que viaja deus passa de 250
quilômetros por segundo por exemplo e
que essa tentação vertiginosa não fosse
mais do que uma vertigem passageiro só
isso mas não era peter sempre às vezes
esquecemos que os dilemas sobre o
próximo passo da humanidade só são
possíveis porque o futuro é o
patrocinador oficial das imperfeições
humanas desde 2006 e maio de anos mais
ou menos
mas sendo assim os turcos e docentes
será ativo para nos questionemos claro
acerca dos seus próximos passos
muito provavelmente nada o que será mais
inquietante no modo como os anunciantes
vivem o próximo
a reforma com parece não acreditar
perdida - o futuro o modo como parece
não ver como uma clareira um dos seus
sonhos ganhou vida e forma e tração é
ter e como imagina no essencial como
paraíso fiscal para tudo que é fácil que
parece imaginar a ser surdo um futuro
muito grande
famosos e financeiramente por trás por
quê pergunta é por que sonham por si e
pelos seus pais
ao mesmo tempo como se não cedessem
todas as oportunidades se imaginarem a
caminho do futuro um passo atrás do
outro
talvez porque os pais parecem viver
seqüestrados no presente e acreditar
pouco mesmo muito pouco no estúdio
aliás eu acho que há é patrimônios
imateriais da humanidade que não só que
nós nos suínos como aquilo que era antes
aos docentes
o próximo passo do seu crescimento como
o erro
o engano e o falhamos que cada vez que
os aproveitamos nos tornam sabes como a
dor é dupla o nosso crescimento como
vergonha
c qual nós lutamos seu orgulho como
esperanças qat precisamos intensamente
para acreditar ea paixão que aquilo que
nos permite escutar os outros em 9 que o
que sentimos tudo ao mesmo tempo
sem recuar ao nunca se olha argumento
nos anos o que será mais em que é tanto
no modo como os anunciantes vivem o
próximo passo é a forma como estamos a
obrigar a crescer suas cadeiras e
camarotes
estamos cargas absurdas trabalho ranking
15 metas e precisamos fazer esquecer que
havia urgência conjunto mora fora de
tempo
os torna tristes exemplos por outras
palavras obrigamos a trabalhar para os
resultados escolares e deixamos que
proíbe sempre o que é mais importante
como exemplo a namorar com a vida o que
é que é mais em que tanto no modo como
os 800 viver o próximo passo é forma é
como nos resignamos a falar com eles por
silêncios por murmúrios ricos gás ou em
160 que acontece porque não os escutamos
neres falamos produzir cutâneo como se o
português de forma comeu se usa esse
funda
não fosse o que é o que há de mais
essencial para pensar e aquilo que é
mais importante para ligar corpo e
pensamento
o que é que é mais em que até no modo
como os alunos chineses vivem o próximo
passo
o modo como confundimos caught e
pensamento como se pensar pela positiva
vamos pensar em uma espécie de
pensamento sem dó e os treinos para a
escola lhes damos fórmulas tipo fast
food para que sejam felizes e
tranquilizamos autor juiz esquecendo que
são os nós fizemos de pais quer mais os
ensina
e é verdade como eles falamos que mais
cresce e as 12 do crescimento que hoje
possa e viver juntos nós que é mais
estranho é capaz para viver com os
conflitos com a frustração e inclusive
sucesso
o que será mais em que tanto nós como os
adolescentes que vivem próximo passo é
forma como os baralhamos confundindo
sexualidade amor assumindo com as
tacitamente foi a ânsia dos pilotos mais
pressa por fora do que prudente e
vivemos a sexualidade antes dos
procurados no amor que talvez tenha
feito com que o amor pelos nossos filhos
presentes para muitos de vitória de
consolação do que cento mamada a
cancelar o ano com um número assustador
mensagens escritas que os 220 os dias e
por isso reclama que o lugar da nossa
espécie possa ser no futuro
provavelmente muito de frente
mas quem é que toca arrasta ou clica no
telemóvel 2617 vezes por dias 11 números
dos estúdios mais fidedignos são os pais
e os 200
quem tem por isso uma atenção parcial
contínua parcial
mesmo com quando foi no estado ligado
são os pais com os docentes
e quem tem por isso mesmo é uma atitude
que limita forma voluntária a sua
influência
os pais das escolas que estão
liberalizado uma forma estréia hoje tava
e usando cenas e quem por isso mesmo
dessa quebra não crescia representativa
se vai deixando substituir vezes mais
pelo populismo pela manipulação pela
vulnerabilidade e pelos efeitos
perversos das redes sociais
e quem parece deixar pacificamente que a
humanidade se encontra na natureza
humana
disputamos os pais para o próximo passo
que os futuros devem ser hoje mesmo esta
hora de forma que não olhem invejosa
mente para tudo aquilo que desceu
navegávamos encetarem e para que não
projeto 'nossa docentes os perigos de
uma docência que os próprios pais não
viveram esse será o primeiro desafio dos
pais em relação ao próximo passo dos
cientistas em direção ao futuro
o segundo passo será a pulsar
conciliarem conhecimento de que se
encontraram sendo us 200 o terceiro terá
encontro novamente a ver com o modo como
precisar um dia de serviço e delimitar a
relação dos sentimentos próprios
mas com a adição de novas tecnologias e
não tem 201 da liberdade do pensamento e
da autodeterminação tínhamos com a
escolha
o quarto finalmente servirá para lhes
lembrar incansavelmente que o futuro
aceitar pessoas e facas e que sem isso
não há quem cresças transformar esses
acre um passo atrás do outro pegava
[Aplausos]
[Música]